hey guys it's me period and it's Friday
so you know what that means
[Music]
ready crows got your real bamboozle
there didn't you you thought it was
frying as we purify look why YouTube's
favorite show that's right everybody
look why we're you guys post a meme and
I will review them prediction let's see
here
outdated memes while commenting at me
sing let's begin everybody I'm excited I
never understand the fifth issue of
whatever her name what's her name
Eiling McBeal I never understood it okay
she's the kind of girl that's like top
of the clients everyone loves and that
you secretly want to run a lawnmower
over you ever had a girl like that hey
look it's me everybody
Esposito - hey hey Monica - yeah we got
to do another one we got to do another
one wait what pure Smurfs are making me
the new boots what do you guys do
alright what did you steal
dude you got to remove the sticker don't
be that guy that doesn't remove the
sticker that's a quite hairy knife
what's up my nine-year-olds how's it
going everybody hope you're enjoying
this video so far please join my
giveaway where we're giving it away this
like and comment I love nine-year-olds
and hit that Bell button and you're in
hummingbird booming bird that's right
the me is sick you clearly spun it the
wrong way by the way just it's supposed
to go in the right direction of the body
you won't twirl the opposite direction
you dummy meme correction now do it
again and do it right
what a nice rule head they are having
today stupid mother nature errand
snap yes mrs. ko
we need to do a PewDiePie another
PewDiePie cringe Gloria Borger retired
but we still have these brave journalist
that's right the Pew News team does have
a lot of employees after all we're a
very broad large news organization when
a comeback hits you 10 times harder
you finally count someone well done to
Bryant last time you played the game you
nearly killed your effing career well at
least I killed someone
India 3.5 million China 4.3 at that at
that at that army of nine-year-olds yeah
all he had to do was put fortnight in
the title he finally understands the
algorithm I found damn it to Chrissy day
in fortnight number one I'm trending
haha what a weird coincidence out of all
my videos little TV do blew up sorry
sorry for catching guys oops I just get
really passionate about these things
like the little David he already has 7.2
million where is the trendy where is the
trending it doesn't make any sense we
didn't pick the trendy guys we swear
Yeah right and it's more arid up here
Oh old woman our cream if she streams oh
I didn't see he wrote streams she's that
I can't say that word I would never say
that word because all woman are queen
let's get this is scare PewDiePie a
season 3 intro OH
which will never happen let's make this
corn a meme so boots is disappointed I'm
not disappointed that this is the
standard so I don't know what you guys
are on about waiting for 63 million suns
okay someone caught the moment hey whoa
you got an exact moment that's dumb all
watching thank you guys to all my 63
million nine year olds really means a
lot to have so many nine year olds
watching my channel it makes me so happy
that I have this army of children I
actually like the new PewDiePie more
than the old PewDiePie well I like NOPD
Pi so thank you very much for this
garbage I wonder what I did to enter I
think the lace is a little longer than
that oh my god the list is just gonna
keep growing you know what am i Russia's
when Pierce call you a 9 year old but
you're 1010 more than a month ago that's
literally impossible 10 year olds go
straight to ali-a
okay petition for PewDiePie to make
every meme into boaters me don't be
ridiculous I wouldn't waste such
precious valuable resources for nothing
okay fine you know what fine I prefer
the real Queen I said the real Queen
perfection aren't you proud Brad okay
moving on
nice sign but can you do this can you do
this no how is this one still going just
let it go guys
Jesus Christ no I didn't laugh shut up
I'll eat my like testicle promise if
belief equates if we never uploads the
video I'm serious
100% I'm saying right now it's not a
call-out I will eat my left teste it
nicer now doesn't it feel better now it
does doesn't it it feels it feels good
I'm not saying it to be mean but it
feels better
10 famous people ruined by drugs so I
just saw this tweet on meit's online
it's amazed and I just spent about 20
minutes trying to figure out how to get
to the end because there's nothing
better to do with my life at this point
and after like 5 minutes of trying to
figure this out I noticed that there was
a bucket here and just use the bucket
tool and it's gonna become an okay sign
it's gonna become an okay bucket tool I
set it to black and I clicked on the
white space right here oh my god what an
absolute genius how did he figure this
out I don't know Oh oh my god goddamnit
snap this is going in my cringe
compilation snap this is got snap snap
snaps oh my god you guys are actually
nine year old how about that I didn't
realize I thought it was just a joke
where is he going to come out
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right we have we have two two
types of people watching me
nine-year-olds and soy boys everybody
basically how I'm still able to make
videos after eight flippin years okay
PewDiePie it's Kai Lowell twitch
thoughts everybody female twitch
streamer showing ass on her stream Wow
everybody did I tell you about ass by
the way it's out game of the year
edition finally out check it out
description PewDiePie
63 million subscribers are these all
active users Oh what what do you don't
be silly of course they are that's why I
get 63 million views on every single one
of my upload think about it out of the
almost 63 million yes some of them are
dead f-u-n like how how confident the
title is 100% going to be in the little
I kind of feel like cutting it out just
because of that well I guess I never saw
this one
alright why did no one show me this Phil
it's not my fault when you send her a
cute message I think for Bob and vakani
but instead you get of getting a reply
you end up getting 55 video everybody
the ultimate honor the ultimate pleasure
there's nirvana but they're all Indians
are seeking you're welcome by the way
upload supa dupa has to explain to us
why he suddenly has good video quality
well I'm using the the camera I bought
in Japan it's got 4k so now you see all
my pimples and joy everybody enjoy that
was it for this weeks of love hope you
guys enjoy watching this one thank you
guys for all the memes if you want to
submit link is in the description thank
you for leaving like join the giveaway
guys it said really a really good one
hate sorry it's gonna be great I'll see
you guys next Friday for the next week
of freshman beard
that's it for me for now love you guys
so much
all my nine year old came as